but what we do is pretty amazing the
general context is of course we develop
medicines that hopefully can alleviate
pain and suffering from different
diseases what I do specifically here is
I work as part of a project team we're
very fortunate we get to work with all
the different disease areas so whether
it's the cardiovascular area or
infectious disease or diabetes cancer
group each of those disease areas has
target proteins and so then our job is
to work with the gene expression people
who actually do the DNA cloning and will
clone the DNA that expresses that target
protein into different kind of hosts so
some maybe e coli like recombinant e
coli some maybe mammalian cells like
chinese hamster ovary cells human
embryonic kidney cells and some maybe
this is the really amazing part like an
insect cell virus and so our job is to
express these target proteins in these
different hosts and once we're able to
do that we find the best host that makes
the most protein our job then is to
scale up these cell lines and express
these proteins where they will then get
purified by another group and then used
for the therapeutic area target of
interest so it would be used for
high-throughput screening it could be
used to identify the structure of the
protein can be used an assay development
and the therapeutic area so when you
think about the drug discovery train the
pipeline we're kind of in the front
because without these target proteins
there's not a lot of screening and that
these target proteins there's no biology
then that can be done to identify these
new medicines
so we will work with each of the
different therapeutic areas so each
therapeutic area of course we're all
experts in our field so if the area is
let's say diabetes they will be
targeting a protein or a specific
biochemical pathway let's say in the
Cascade of diabetes in the body and
they're hoping to identify a novel
medicine or a new Pfizer medicine and
will somehow stimulate or block or
somehow modulate that protein to move
that disease in a positive direction so
the first step then is for the project
team to identify these targets the
second step then would be for the for
the gene cloning people and myself to
work with these project teams and
identify the DNA sections that they want
to clone into these let's say hosts
let's call them hoes and so once they do
that they determine whether or not
they're making the right protein and
then those hosts come into our lab where
we will scale them up to sometimes as
high as 100 leaders and it's pretty
amazing this recombinant DNA technology
because these hosts not only make their
own cell proteins they make the protein
from the DNA that was cloned into it
well of course when I started there
weren't computer process controlled
sterilized one place for manners and so
it's been really great to see just the
cell culture technology take off in the
25 years now we have automated cell
counters and automative analyzers that
can test the chemistry's of these cell
lines in just minutes whereas years ago
we used to have to count the cells on
you know microscope using a microscope a
hemocytometer now we can get cell counts
in just a matter of minutes and so the
technology has allowed us to do much
more in a much shorter period of time
today we have all kinds of tagged
proteins so we can put on histidine tags
and GST tags and flag tags on to these
proteins and so that really makes the
purification so much quicker because we
can use affinity chromatography so maybe
when I started might take a whole month
or three months to purify one protein
now we can do almost the whole thing in
just a week or sometimes just a few days
the technology has really allowed us to
do much more in a shorter period of time
so it's these protein targets that we're
trying to identify novel medications to
either block or inhibit or stimulate
these target proteins so our job is to
scale up these cell lines that make
these target proteins now what's amazing
is niche of these cell lines they may
only express maybe one milligram per
liter which is a very very small amount
and so one of the important things of
our job then is to either use our novel
technologies which could be different
kinds of bioreactors another point would
be to somehow optimize the expression of
the protein using again different
technologies different media different
growth conditions may be using substrate
feeding these types of technologies to
increase the tighter or the level of
expression of these proteins the more
protein we have are able to express the
easier it becomes to pure
phy once they purify this protein like I
said it may only be one milligram per
liter that pure protein can then be sent
back to the therapeutic area where they
can wear it can be used in a
high-throughput screening assay so they
can I try and identify pfizer compounds
novel medicines that will work against
this protein in a positive way and so
that's one of the ways in which we
impact drug discovery a second way would
be many of these target proteins are
novel we don't know what they look like
which is kind of awesome and so what
they'll do is we will purify this
protein and we will give it to the
structure chemists and what they will do
is try and crystallize the protein and
then get the crystalline structure now
once you have the crystalline structure
the protein then you can use what's
called computer-aided drug discovery so
you can maybe model the structure of the
protein and try and find the binding
site and actually synthetically design a
drug that may block or turn on or
stimulate the protein which ever way
we're trying to modify that protein to
affect the target disease area
I think the exciting part is when you're
able to get a crystal structure of a
protein and then you're able to design a
drug and you can actually see how that
drug inhibits the disease that's very
exciting because we all win the project
team wins the gene expression people win
the people that scale up and do the
large-scale fermentation and cell
culture work that I do win purification
people win it's we all the teams win so
and one of us is successful really all
successful is the way it is I wish you
could see it because it's actually kind
of simple if you think of like a ziploc
bag starla ziploc bag on a rocker and
the technology was actually discovered
in the mid-1990s and at that time they
said this will never work and so we are
very fortunate to get one of the first
of these wave rocking platforms and what
we actually do is we take this imagine
it looks like a ziploc bag we fill it
with median cells and then it rocks on a
platform back and forth and the cells
really like this motion and so our cells
if they're mammalian cells or even
insect cells because these types of
cells can grow in suspension we can grow
them to very high cell densities and
with very high cell viability and so the
more cells we have the more protein we
can make because happy cells are
productive cells and so it's it's an
exciting technology because previous to
the wave bioreactor all the work was
done in stirred tank fermenters and so a
stirred tank for a mentor had to be
assembled the probes all had to be
calibrated it had to be sterilized in an
autoclave it had to be brought back at
some times washed through with
conditioned media then we would actually
add cells to it run it and of course in
a stirred tank you have a an impeller
that spin
around you have air that's being sparged
through it and so every time those cells
mammalian cells and insect cells
remember they're very fragile they don't
have a cell cell wall like bacteria they
just have a cell membrane so they're
very fragile every time the cells would
hit the impeller are the sides of the
stirred tank or one of these bubbles
would pop the cells would die so the
design of this gentle rocking motion
wave bioreactor allows the cells to be
in a happy environment where they are
much more viable and they can grow too
much higher cell densities and so that's
the technology the bags come sterile and
so we just hook the bag up fill it with
our cells and media and they make them
now up to 500 liters maybe larger which
is really awesome but in our lab we just
go up to we have run multiple batches of
25 liters so again as I said at first
nobody thought this would work I mean
it's kind of such a novel idea everybody
said well geez that's kind of silly
it'll never work but here at Pfizer we
were able to show that the technology
did work it saved tremendous amounts of
time and money and because the bags came
sterile and then were disposable there
was no washing and cleaning and
assembling and assembling it was just
let's grow the cells let's make the
protein and let's move on to the next
one
one of the projects that were working
right on right now is in 2 diabetes
areas you know diabetes over time is a
very debilitating disease and so
wouldn't it be great to have a medicine
that you could just take orally let's
say and help control your diabetes or
wouldn't it be a wouldn't it be great to
develop some kind of gene technology so
that we could cure diabetes again
there's so many opportunities in these
areas obesity and a terrible disease
wouldn't it be great to develop a drug
to help control people that can't help
but be overweight wouldn't it be great
to develop in any cancer therapy that
would cure any kind of cancer that would
be awesome so all these areas and I
think today's tonight technology
provides tremendous hope because even
five years ago some of these
technologies weren't known some of these
monoclonal antibodies that are in a
clinic today will hopefully save
millions of lives just five years from
now and so the area of technology brings
tremendous hope
you